[Musique]
on n'a que dix salles barbe est le nom
donné à un filet de pêche mesalles barbe
c'est aussi le nom d'un groupe qui
attrapent dans ses filets des rythmes
acadien cajun classe que toute notre âme
est un cri d'amour pour l'acadie
notre
après un premier album récompensé par
l'adisq salle vabre revient avec john à
l'eau salée un disque enregistré en
pleine pandémie et à distance il y avait
que j'avais baptisé mugello
et quand j'aurai maintenant un mix d'une
des chansons là je me suis vu dans lance
et devant la tente d'un café dans le
salon avant un beau but là à 2h30 du
matin la seule la noire le candidat ok
moi j'ai
avec à bord les madelinots eloi et
jonathan painchaud et les néo
brunswickois jean françois breau kevin
mcintyre george belliveau salle barbe
rend hommage entre autres à d'autres
chats en adaptant son louisiane amman
pour le transformer en gagner sa vie
la royauté de la royauté acadienne tant
que choix pour ce qui est ici ça c'est
une légende
c'est le premier rééditer au johnny cash
show
toujours avec son caractère festif
sainte-barbe reprend aussi avec ce
deuxième album une chanson de chuck
berry s'est dit
choqué premier on vous laisse faire un
beau petit feu qui on avait du bois pour
s'amuser mons après le feu mais alors ça
parce qu'on a des canisses de garde
salle barbe est inspiré par le
répertoire acadiens et cajun mais aussi
par la relève musicale de l'est du pays
les jeunes
se renouvelle
[Musique]
l'album jean à l'eau salée est lancée ce
soir sur facebook en direct du vieux
trucs des îles de la madeleine ici les
prix mais radio-canada moria
[Musique]